I want everybody here to think that they
live the same life Island which is
you're being filmed at all times and I
want you to think every time that you're
with somebody in the office talking
about somebody else in the office that
it's being filmed and everybody can
watch it I'll tell you where I'm going
with that the Vayner way is being nice
to each other not as like a thing on our
[__] wall as like real it's not like
I'm like let's double our head count or
let's get four new big clients I have no
goals other than for you when I see you
in a year when I'm here and we walk by
each other and I ask you are you as
happy as you were when you told me that
a year ago and you're like yes I'm like
did you learn stuff yes I'm like then
we're winning those are my two passions
great culture great craft a year from
now I just want to be better at both